es el sistema de estas dos ecuaciones
lineales que tenemos a continuación
independiente o dependiente de estas dos
que tenemos aquí y bueno antes de saber
si es dependiente o independiente sería
muy bueno saber que es ser independiente
o ser dependiente y curiosamente para
saber que es independiente y que es
dependiente necesitamos saber primero
que es que sean consistentes o
inconsistentes dos ecuaciones lineales
así que para esto voy a dibujar tres
planos cartesianos con las tres posibles
situaciones que puedan pasar con dos
líneas rectas este va a ser mi primer
plano cartesiano este es mi eje de las x
ni eje de lajes aquí voy a dibujar mi
segundo plano cartesiano este va a ser
mi eje de las x este va a ser mi que de
las guías y voy a dibujar un tercer
plano cartesiano aquí va a ser mi eje de
las x este va a ser mi eje de leyes y
bueno para que tres planos cartesianos
bueno pues supongamos que yo tengo dos
líneas rectas en un plano cartesiano que
puede pasar con estas dos líneas rectas
déjenme ponerlo de otro color que mi
primera línea recta sea ésta y mi
segunda línea recta sea ésta y se
intersectan
un solo punto esta es la primera de las
situaciones que podrían pasar entre dos
líneas rectas la segunda y mejor dejen
medio de ponerle aquí es que tenga dos
líneas rectas que sean paralelas es
decir que nunca se toquen nunca se
conozcan y por lo tanto como son
paralelas que tengan también la misma
pendiente pero que no corten en el mismo
lado al eje de las diez y la tercera
situación es que sean la misma recta es
decir que tanto como la primera como la
segunda ecuación mete en la misma línea
recta o dicho de otra manera que se
junten en una infinidad de puntos y
bueno este tercer plano cartesiano en
donde tenemos el caso en el que son
paralelas es decir donde nunca se
intersectan se conoce como un sistema
inconsistente un sistema inconsistente
es cuando tenemos dos rectas paralelas
es decir nunca se intersectan y estos
dos casos en donde se intersectan en un
punto o dónde se intersectan en una
infinidad de puntos se desconoce como un
sistema consistente y bueno en los
sistemas consistentes hay de dos casos o
que sean la misma recta es decir que se
intersecta en una infinidad de puntos
perfecto en solamente un punto y cuando
se intersectan en solamente un punto se
les conoce con el nombre de que estas
dos ecuaciones son independientes estas
dos rectas son independientes sus
sistemas independientes si se
intersectan en solamente un punto
mientras que en el otro caso hablamos de
un sistema dependiente o de que las dos
ecuaciones son dependientes y fíjate lo
que nos preguntan nos preguntan si estas
dos ecuaciones son dependientes o
independientes esto quiere decir que por
detrás ya no están diciendo que el
sistema es un sistema consistente
ahora habrá que fijarnos si estas dos
rectas intersectan en un solo punto o se
intersectan en una infinidad de puntos
es decir son la misma recta y bueno para
resolver esto hay varias formas de
hacerlo ya mí se me ocurre hacerlo de la
forma más fácil porque si te das cuenta
la segunda ecuación que tenemos aquí ya
está de la forma que es igual a mx + b
ya que claramente se nota cuál es la
pendiente la pendiente sería menos 2 y
cuánto vale b es decir la ordenada al
origen que vale 8 qué les parece si
hacemos que la primera ecuación se vea
también de la misma forma y es igual a
mx
así que vamos a hacerlo lo primero que
se me ocurre es restar de los dos lados
a 4x para pasar el 4x del otro lado de
la ecuación entonces recuerden que tras
lo que voy es despejar ayer para saber
cuál es muy pendiente y cuáles no
ordenada al origen de la primera
ecuación entonces voy a poner menos 4 x
4 x 4 x 4 x se van entonces me queda que
2 es igual a menos 4 x más 16 lo
siguiente que voy a hacer es dividir
todo entre 2 para que me quede
completamente despejada la y entonces
voy a decir que esto es entre 2 estos
entre 2 y estos entre 2 por lo tanto 2 y
entre 2 me quedan menos 4 x entre 2 me
quedan menos 2x y 16 entre 2 me queda 8
ya viste cuando el espejo ayer en la
primera ecuación me queda que es ni más
ni menos que la segunda ecuación esto es
lo mismo que la segunda ecuación te das
cuenta y qué quiere decir eso que
entonces tenemos la misma pendiente
fíjate bien aquí tenemos las dos
pendientes son iguales que entonces
tenemos también la me
ordenada al origen las dos ordenadas del
origen son iguales y esto quiere decir
que ni más ni menos que si tenemos la
misma pendiente y también tenemos la
misma ordenada estamos hablando de que
es la misma recta fíjate bien cortan en
igual a 8 y tienen una pendiente
negativa así que va por aquí la primera
recta vamos a suponer que esta es mi
primera recta esta recta que tengo aquí
una pendiente negativa y corta en día
igual a 8 ahora mi segunda recta también
corta en de igual a 8 y además tiene una
pendiente negativa y de la misma
magnitud por lo tanto podemos decir que
este sistema es de pendiente estas dos
ecuaciones son ecuaciones dependientes
porque son la misma recta nos vemos en
el siguiente vídeo